you get obsessed with things sometimes I
mean very obsessed and you really get
into it right and then you just sort of
drop it one day and you move on and you
get obsessed with something else what is
your latest obsession what's the thing
you're obsessed with these days k-pop
k-pop explain explain to those who don't
know what k-pop is it's a global
phenomenon so I'm sure that everyone
already knows there are people out there
there are some people who thought you're
talking about a weird drug it's the hot
new thing yeah
no it's it's Korean pop music yeah and
it's some beyond excellent it's the best
thing you've ever seen it's the best
thing you've ever seen in its what is it
about is it the videos is it the music
is it the whole thing combined it's kind
of all of it it's like although the
company I don't know what it is it's
like it's like um it's like a it's like
I don't even know how to describe it
it's just it's a it's all so addictive
yeah do you very addictive do you do you
have a current favorite well when we
were in when we did the spider-man
premiere in Seoul Korea we were on stage
with a band called 2ne1 and do you see
of that band they come to every show
kpop band has like 15 members that's
what's weird - yeah well this would only
is four oh really
there are a lot of like Girls Generation
that's another one okay so this this
group what is what is the song that you
like I like a song called I am the best
which I am not going to try to to say in
Korean but it's incredible and the
lyrics is no other song - I'm like way
behind the lyrics of the song about
being the best yeah it's just like I am
the best I am the best I am the best
I feel like I just singing that song
here that's what I'm saying that's not a
thing in the mirror that's what happened
we have a clip because we heard of it
this is your song herewith I am the best
kpop what's the name of the group again
it to anyone take a look
[Music]
okay I want to have would you come back
if Andy and I did a night where it was
just those three chairs that spin around
those chairs it's kind of like being on
the voice but cooler but here is a dare
I say